hey friends welcome back to the deep
dive snippet this is a little clip from
my conversation with julian hearn who
founded the company huel at the age of
37. he bootstrapped heel to over 40
million pounds in annual revenue within
four years of launching heel was valued
at around 250 million dollars and just
within four years of launching heal was
valued at 220 million pounds and
julian's story is really inspiring about
how it's never too late to start a
business if that's what you want to do i
was trying to work out what age you
started various companies and it was
like surprisingly later in life than
people would initially think people
think founders like you know 17 to 19
year olds mark zuckerberg the stripe
guys yeah um but you were like 30
something when you started i would have
been 36 37
and um yeah i yeah most of these sort of
podcasts can focus around the sort of
very younger guys and yeah you think
about the zuckerberg because the world
is incredibly young well i think you've
done ben francis reasoning incredibly
young so i think that it's um
yeah i think it's interesting that most
people probably think when they get 36
day seven they're sort of stuck in what
they're doing yeah they can't retrain
they can't relearn
but yeah i did i just sort of had a had
a need had a personal reason why i
needed to start working from home
and i had to suss that out and i did a
lot of stuff you sort of do is listen to
a lot of podcasts tons of podcasts
read a lot online
and try and work out and sort of bodge
your way through to start off with so it
took me about a year before i got the
confidence to jack my job in but worked
evenings and weekends
yeah it must be 36.87 yeah so when you
so um i i speak to a lot of people in
their like so sometimes even late teens
but like early to mid-20s who say oh i
don't know what i want to do i haven't
figured it out yeah it seems like all
these other people are sort of like
going ahead of me yeah um
what was your kind of experiences during
school and sort of like late teens early
20s um and how did how did we go from
that to
and then starting a business like
so i left school at 16
um pretty poor gcses um what did i get
three c's maybe these e's got two e's
for english i do remember that i can't
spell i'm not really gonna read it
either really it's got two years of
english left at 16
worked at a shop for a year then worked
digging holes in the road for two years
as manual labor
then i think my girlfriend at time was
about 90 she goes what are you doing
digging holes in the road you're too
smart to do that so i wasn't
academically smart i saw quite smart at
certain stuff
so i went back to college
two years
uh and i thought i'd come out of there
and get a job came out of college with
two uh i think it was a b tech i had
couldn't get a job off the back of that
so i had nothing else to do really apart
from went to uniform now i'm committed
i've given up work i might as well keep
going so then i got a placement at
bournemouth university did a degree in
marketing came out of that thought i'd
get a job straight away no problem
didn't actually work i remember i worked
night shifts in the petrol station for
six months
and um
and then luckily i think it was my
stepmom she worked with somebody whose
husband worked somewhere and luckily i
got a job in marketing finally after all
that so i'd had a degree mark had a 2-1
but couldn't get a job luckily i got one
i worked in the marketing team
from about i think that must be 1999
something like that worked in marketing
for mostly retailers so that was when
you were like 25 fish yeah yeah maybe a
little bit older 25 26
and um
and then
then i started uh internet sort of came
along yeah so this was still quite early
because i think when i was at uni i
think i was finishing union 96
and the internet like really not really
about you know i think i think at
university you could use some of the
computers there you could access the
internet but nobody really had a home
computer of internet 96
and um
and then when i first got my job i was
just doing normal sort of marketing as a
marketing assistant and then the
internet came along so somebody said can
you have a look at this internet thing
should we have an internet business i
was working for mfi which is a furniture
retailer at the time then i sort of said
to them yeah it looks like you should
um being q which is a bigger retailer at
the time had a what they call a brochure
where site hadn't you couldn't buy no
e-commerce i said well we could we could
beat them we could overtake them if you
give me some money so i sort of
persuaded the the team or the board to
give us
67 000 pounds and start the first
website
got that built by an agency
got that going and then of course i was
almost a you know within one year i was
almost a great bid in terms of internet
experience because nobody had it so then
i moved on work for some other retailers
and then fast forward to
um
yeah 2000 and
with
2008 i think it was
um
i needed to work from home
because of a personal reason
and um
i thought [ __ ] what i'm going to do
because i lived in the house we were out
and saw out in the countryside i was
working in london and going an hour and
a half each way so it was three hours of
driving a day
so i wanted to work from home no
marketing jobs of any sort of merit in
in aylesbury area so i needed to create
my own business
and uh so i started looking around and
luckily at the time we were using some
affiliates and affiliates are people
basically who sit at home and create
websites
and make money from sitting in their pjs
i suppose at home yeah this is something
i can do maybe these guys i met i met
them i went to an affiliate event and uh
these guys i thought they're making i
knew how much something someone making
like 10 20 000 pounds a month hold your
[ __ ] loads of money
and um
and i met them i thought they were going
to be i don't know i'm not saying their
flight is going to be geniuses but when
i met them i thought they're they're
bright but they're not like rocket
scientists i thought if they can do it
why can't i do it so that was basically
me then thought right i'm going to learn
how to do this by myself by listening to
podcasts
by practicing starting websites learning
learning learning yeah so i used to get
home from work at say six o'clock
on a work day
have my uh meal
with my my wife at a time and then go on
the computer at seven o'clock i
basically had my computer there set up
in the lounge so i could sit in a lounge
watch tv i had a little mirror set up i
could use to watch the tv while i was uh
working yeah and worked to say 11
o'clock
do this at the weekends as well did that
nearly sort of full time for a year yeah
until i got staged where i started
making about a thousand pounds maybe
1500 2 000 pounds a month
and started thinking i know how to do
this if i had more time i could double
the amount of work i would double the
amount of money i could earn
and so i remember saying to my wife at
the time said right
i'm going to have a crack at this
i'm going to jack my job in
i'm going to give myself six months if i
can't get the same amount of money i get
my salary within six months i'll go back
and get that job again i'll get a
similar type of job and i think at that
time i had a good enough experience that
i felt confident i could go back and get
a job so it felt like pretty low risk
and um i thought as long as i could earn
the same salary
and i'm working from home it's a win-win
i've gotten three hours a day i'm not
traveling so that was the goal within
three months i was earning more than my
salary and then he just kept on going
after that yeah i think that's uh when i
think when when when people quit a job
um
i feel like they often have this idea
that oh you know i'm working a 30k job
therefore quitting the job is a 30k risk
but it's actually not because like next
week you could probably get a 28k job if
you really wanted to and so really it's
not a 30k risk it's a 2k risk between
the job that you currently have and the
job that you could pretty easily get if
you need it to and even if you take a
little bit of a pay card maybe you can't
get a 35k job immediately but at least a
25 28k job is is very reasonable in that
context um and i don't know anyone who's
kind of done done that and regretted the
decision because you're sort of like
going all in on yourself and giving
yourself that be like yeah i'm
i've i've i've got to make this work and
if i don't then it's not the end it's
not the end of the world i'll just get
another job if you talk about it and
sort of practice at it forever you're
never going to do it so you do have to
make that hard decision to do it yeah
but i would never i've never would have
done it before i'd been yet practicing
and learning for a year so even as a
weekend was vitally important i think if
you do that and really do it and start
earning money you build confidence the
more you do something the more
confidence you get so i was pretty
confident the end of that year
i said if i double the amount of time i
can work on this or triple the amount of
times i probably could have tripled the
amount of time i know i will do this
yeah so i was pretty confident but yeah
i put enough money to one side to pay
the mortgage pay all the bills for six
months which is not a lot if you just
strip everything out of your life apart
from the mortgage and the food bills you
don't need that much so it wasn't a ton
of cash but i put enough money in the
bank that had that saved that up over
that previous year for the money i had
to earn from it put that to one side
that was enough
um but yeah it was three months and i
was earning more yeah so one well one
thing i i often hear from people is this
idea of
you know i want to do this side hustle
therefore i'm going to quit my job and
i'm going to make it happen i would be
like hang on hang on like don't don't
quit your job until you've at least done
it for a little while yeah in in the
weekends and weekends evenings um but i
guess these days it's it's sort of
become a bit unfashionable to talk about
doing the stuff on the weekends and
evenings and things and everyone's like
oh but like sustainability and like you
know work-life balance and mental health
and all that kind of stuff rightly so
um but i think there is still that
balance between like the people who sort
of succeed are the ones who do add in
that extra level of hustle extra level
of grind if you want to use those words
yeah i i i think that you've all got to
you know to make something work there's
gonna have to be a period of time when
you have to go outside of your comfort
zone you're gonna have to work harder
than you you probably
healthfully should over a long period of
time but you're not doing that forever
so
um that was one year when i
worked crazy crazy amount of hours i'm
doing a full-time job with a three-hour
drive backwards and forwards to home and
a half each way yeah and then working in
the evening so there was crazy hours for
a year big deal i you know i felt like
there was such an end goal at the end of
it it was worth it yeah and then when i
started working at high when i checked
the job i wasn't doing all these
evenings and weekends so there's only
one year
that was pretty
easy in fact i end up started working at
two to finish at two or three o'clock
when somebody started rolling in i was
even finishing early to make up for that
previous year
then i suppose when i started sure that
that that that was tough when that
kicked off there was two to three years
of that when it that was crazy crazy
hours but now i'm 50 years old i've
given you example of basically four
years in total out of 50 while i've
worked crazy hours that feels doable hey
friends thank you so much for watching
if you enjoyed this clip then click here
for the full unedited episode and if you
like that then do please consider
subscribing to the channel it means a
lot thank you so much and have a great
day